Eee ben Fırat Fırat Neziroğlu
Eee uzun yıllardır Eee dokuma yapıyorum
Eee Bu nedir bu dokuma dedik bu dokuma
çok acayip özellikle Anadolu için Çünkü
Eee kilimin dünyadaki adı kilim Eee ilk
e halı Türk düğümü ile dokunmuş zaten
dünyada iki tane düğüm var biri İran
biri de Türk düğümü Eee ve kumaş ilk
kumaşta en eski kumaş çatal öük bulunmuş
Eee Dolayısıyla Biz Eğer bir söz
söyleyeceksen bunun en güzel yolu kendi
dilimizle konuşmak bunlardan bir tanesi
de dokuma Eee şimdi Tabii serüven çok
acayip Çünkü ben başladığımda babamın
zoruyla yani futbolcu bir babam var bir
de ritmik jimnastikçi dünyada ilk dörtte
Eee Olimpik Spor yani Olimpik adayı Bir
sporcu kız kardeşim var Ben de çok uzun
yıllar dans ettim üniversiteye kadar e
zannettim ki babamın zoruyla dans
ederken Utandım da hep çok sahnede Ondan
sonra E bir anda üniversiteye geldiğimde
her şey değişti annemin zoruyla güzel
santlar Fakültesi tekstil bölümüne
girdim Eee şimdi biz hani böyle hep şey
di diyoruz ya Özgür olalım kimse bizi
kısıtlamasını olsun böyle olsun ama
sınır çok önemli bir şeymiş yani sınır
bizim hedefe ne kadar yaklaştığımızı
gösteriyor Dolayısıyla Eee bu bana
çizilen sınırlar içerisindeki o
sonsuzlukta oynamak her zaman çok daha
Eee iyi geldi bana Eee neyse 9 a
Üniversitesi'nde okudum Güzel Sanatlar
Fakültesi tekstil bölümü e içim coşuyor
kaynıyor dans etmek istiyorum ama günde
101 saat masanın başında oturuyorum ve
sadece çizim yapıyorum Eee çok karıştı
Kaf ne yapacağım diye Eee ve sonra
kendime bir oyun alanı buldum Eee ve
dokuma tezgahıyla tanıştım dokuma
tezgahına girdim Allah Allah bir şeyler
dokuyorum ama şöyle oldu Herkes bütün
arkadaşlarım geziyor herkes eğleniyor
İzmir'deyiz müthiş bir eğlence var ve
ben birkaç arkadaşımla birlikte
sabahlara kadar dokuma yapıyorum tezgah
başındayım gün yüzü görmedik yani
günlerce dokuma yaptık Ondan sonra ben
dedim ki bu iş böyle gitmez ben bazı
yerlere dokunayım dokunayım ki kalan
zamanda arkadaşlarımla vakit geçireyim
Eee ve böylece dokumadan bugün
anlamlandı ve dünya Çağdaş sanatı içinde
kendime ait bir dokuma tekniğim oldu Eee
yurt dışında Eee pek çok ülkede ve
Türkiye'de yüksek lisans tezleri yazıldı
bu konuyla ilgili yeni bir düğüm
keşfetmiş oldum durduk yere ondan sonra
ve Eee şimdi üniversitelerde de pek çok
dünyanın pek çok Üniversitesinde ders
olarak anlatılıyor ama anlatılan şey ne
Anadolu tekniği Yani bizim burada
Aslında çok yakından İçimizden özümüzden
Eee müthiş bir Eee bilgimiz var ama hep
şöyle oluyor tam Bence şey hissimiz bu
olabilir arkadaşlarım yurt dışından
geliyorlar Türk değiller E onları ne
yapacağım şeye götürüyorum Topkapı
sarayına diyorum ki bakın buraya E bir
gezdir ik gezdir 5 10 15 artık şey
yapıyorum Ben bir köşede oturuyorum
diyorum buraya gidin Harem burada İşte
mutfak burada falan bir gün bir tane
İtalyan koşa koşa geldi dedi ki ya Fırat
burada inanılmaz bir şey var muhakkak
görmen lazım onu merak ettim yani dedim
kesin gözden kaçırdığım bir şey var Bir
gittim Çin
mutfakta var bizde değil mi
süpürgeliklerde var kumaşlarımız da var
E tuvaletimiz de var yani şimdi bizim
için o kadar sıradan ki biz bu sıradan
şeyi görmeyi unuttuk ve ne yaptık
sürekli hep acaba sadece batı batı değil
yani Batı özentisi Biz hinten de çok
esinlendik uzakdoğu'dan esinlendik
Rusya'dan Avrupa'dan Amerika'dan ya bir
kendimize dönüp bakamadık Neden Çünkü
bizim yaptığımız her zaman işte bize en
çok sıradan gelen şey şimdi böyle olunca
yurt dışında başka birini taklit etmeye
çalışırsak zaten olmuyordu ve bugüne
kadar hiçbir yerde bir Türk bir Anadolu
bir Eee ne diyeyim işte Urfa Mardin
Diyarbakır bunları bir türlü göremez
olduk neden Kendi yaptığımız yorum bile
çok folklorik yani her şeyin içini bugün
giyilemeyeceğine
End iği zaman ya da konar göçerken
ihtiyaçtan dolayı bir kumaş Dokur ya da
bir kilim Dokur halı Dokur Eee çadırını
Dokur bunları dokurken ne yapar Eğer
mesela yeni evlendiyse gittiyse müthiş
diyelim ki huzurlu mutlu bir eve gitti
kayınvalideyle işlerde harika O zaman ne
yapıyor pek çok desen arasından Hayat
Ağacı dokuyor o zaman herkes görüyor
Konu komşu görüyor eş dost görüyor kayın
valide görüyor koca görüyor Hım diyorlar
ki bu buraya bolluk bereket için gelmiş
bu suyu devam ettirmek için gelmiş ama
diyelim ki cızırdıyor kayın valde hle
aralar ortam çok kötü O zaman ne yapıyor
pek çok desen arasan pıtrak dokuyor bunu
dokurken korkmuyor apaçık dokuyor yine
herkes görüyor O zaman anlıyor ki pıtrak
ne dışarı çıktığımızda eteklerin
uçlarına pantolonların paçalarına böyle
dikenli Otlar yapışır Onlar her yerde
vardır doğada ondan sonra biz onları eve
girerken ya da işte ilgili yere girerken
elimizle temizleriz dikenler bize batar
yani kayın valide diyor bak Sen bana
batıyorsun buradan bunu söylerken güçlü
ama şimdi şey düşünelim Ben şimdi
pıtrağı açıklamak zorunda kaldım ya
şimdi diyelim ki ben bugün pıtrak 5 tane
dokunuyormuş kilimde Ben 20 tane dokudum
e pıtrak kahverengiyi sarıy mış maviymiş
Ben bugün neon renklerle dokudum Hadi
bakalım ben bunu
modernleştirmek olmuyor çünkü bu bir dil
bir iletişim dili ve Bugün ben pıtrağı
görsem tanımam Neden Çünkü sokağa
çıktığımda çamur var asfalt var bina var
beton var biraz ağaç var Yeşillik de
çimden ibaret E şimdi onlar da her gün
topar ıyor falan tertemiz E şimdi böyle
olunca dil anlaşılmıyor O zaman ben
modernleştirmek
çağdaşa taşıdım vesaire derken aslında
çok önemli bir yeri kaçırıyorum manayı
yani Biz sürekli şekle takılıp şekiller
şekiller yaptığımız için bir türlü
manada buluşamıyoruz işte onun
buluşmasında da beni en çok etkileyen
şey göz göze bakışmak oldu çünkü
iletişimin hiç değişmeyen dili duygular
gibi geliyor bana ve göz göze bakışıp
anlaştığımız Eee Mümkün Mertebe her
şeyden daha çok çok anlaşıyor uşun gibi
geliyor Dolayısıyla Bugün o kadının o
adamın dokuduğu kilimlerin üzerindeki
motiflerin anlamını bugünkü insanların
gözlerinden anlatmayı tercih ediyorum
Dolayısıyla ben aslında geleneksel bir
Anadolu kilimi de okuyorum şimdi
sürdürülebilirlikle ilgili Buradayız Ne
oluyor ne bitiyor
E bu çok acayip bir şey çünkü hep
biliyoruz mesela kırk yama diye bir şey
var bugün patchwork diye herkes
konuşuyor ana dilin çok önemli olduğunu
düşünüyorum Ana dilde sadece kelime
değil kelimenin manasının da bize bugüne
geldiğini düşünüyorum 40k yama yırtılmış
parçalanmış üzülmüş ezilmiş bir kısmın
yeniden mutlu olması demek aslında kumaş
dilinde kumaş böyle birazcık bozulsa biz
şey deriz Anadolu'da böyle üzüldü derler
kumaşın orası üzülmüş onu tekrar mutlu
eder ama patchwork deyince parça işi
oluyor bakın birbirini tam tamamlamıyor
bile o zaman yaptığımız işle bağımız
arasında da bir şey oluyor mesafe oluyor
şimdi anneanne en ufak çorabı kaçıyordu
çorabı kaçtıktan sonra sonra hop bir
şeyleri e tekrar yerine getiriyordu Şey
yapıyordu çorabı kaçıyordu Ondan sonra
bulaşık bezi yapıyordu falan filan Şimdi
sürdürülebilirlikte şöyle yıllardır
Anadolu'nun her köşesini geziyorum
kumaşları çıkarıyorum e kadınlarla
buluşuyorum eski usul neler yapılıyormuş
Ankara keçim var çok önemli bakarsanız
görürsünüz müthiş bir tarihi var Ve
bugün hiç yoktu şimdi bugün 225.000 baş
geçi yaptık Şile'de Şile Bezi dokunmaz
oranın tuz oranı vardır dünyada sadece
Şile'nin denizinde bir tuz oranı vardır
ve onu kullanırlar kumaşı dokurken
denizde dokunur resmen kumaş onlar da
tekrar üst tezgah kurduk 200 tezgahta
200 kadına 3 senedir ders veriyorum
orada yeniden çıktı saymayın şimdi böyle
bir sürü yer bizim sürdürülebilirlik
için en önemli şeyimiz şu bir kumaşı
geri dönüştürdüğünü de bir yıl
kullanabiliyorsunuz Sadece bir kere
ikinci kere yapamıyorsunuz o yine çöp
oluyor ve onu geri dönüştürmek için yine
su harcadık Yine elektrik harcadık yine
karbon kizi oluşturduk yani
Sürdürülebilir de dediğimiz şey aslında
Çok da Sürdürülebilir değil biz pamuğu
pamuk gibi yapsak 10 yıl kullanırız Ama
bir kere geri dönüştürdüğümüz ipliği
Ertesi yıl yeniden çöp yapıyoruz yani şu
Tasarımın Eee sanatın zanaatın bizi
çeken müthiş o rengi deseni tasarımı her
şeyi bize çok önemli bir sorumluluk daha
veriyor çünkü yaptığımız şey en güzel en
değerli en fevkalade de olsa Eninde
sonunda Çöp bu çöp bir dünyaya müdahale
Biz müdahale Yolumuz çok iyi seçmeliyiz
Dolayısıyla yaptığımız şeyde Hadi
bakalım dijital olarak ne olur şimdi
şunu nasıl çözerim Bunların hepsine
varım ama biz yiyen içen giyinen ve
yaşayan insanlarız ve bu dünyanın içinde
Sadece burada yaşayabiliyoruz
Dolayısıyla buradaki müdahale
sistemimizi çok iyi inceleyip tekrar
harekete geçirmek lazım en önemli
konulardan bir tanesi işte Ankara Tiftik
keçisinin lifi çok önemlidir hemen
Kısaca söyleyeyim Eee Ankara keçisi
1930'lar kadar ta Osmanlı'dan beri yavaş
yavaş buradan kaçırıldı ve biliyor
musunuz endemik tür endemik tür dışarı
çıkarmak yasak siyaha boyayıp Kaçırdılar
Avrupa'da denediler e Güney Afrika'da
denediler en sonunda e keçi gittikçe hep
yozlaştı hep bozuldu yergök Ankara
tiftik
keçisiyle ve baktılar ki 3 4 kalitesi
buldular ve bunlar NASA'nın uzay
kıyafetlerinin ham maddesi olarak
kullanıldı Biz biliyoruz ki Ankara
tiftik keçisi lifi olup pulcuk özelliği
olmadığı için keçeleşme Nadir türlerden
Bir tanesi çok ince sizi Müthiş ısıyla
koruyabilen çok hafif kumaşlar dokunur
Bunlar sof kumaşları dır ve yoktu şimdi
biz 2018'de Ankara'da tarım Orman İl
Müdürlüğü ile birlikte önce toprak
analizleri Ondan sonra yetiştirilecek
bitkiler Ondan sonra da Çoban
yetiştirerek
Ankara keçilerinin tekrar Eee bugün
çoğalması için çalışıyoruz ve 225.000
baş keçi yaptık E buradan da Süleyman
Demirel Üniversitesi'nin bir taraf bir
taraftan Süleyman Demirel
Üniversitesi'nde de üniversite danışma
kurulunda orada da radyoloji bölümünde
UV testleri ve ışık hastlıkları
yapılıyor Çünkü keçinin kendinden UV
filtresi var yani biz Güneşten korunmak
için Oramı buramı bir sürü şeyler
sürüyoruz Ama buna hiç gerek yok aslında
yani Bilişim vadisinde yim giyilebilir
teknolojiler danışmanıyım orada tek işim
şu bu dünyada doğal ya da E doğal lif
hayvansal ya da bitkisel kendi
varoluşuyla bize ne faydası var Biz
sürekli bir şeylerin içine kendi
bilgimizi katmaya çalışır olduk kendi
düşüncemizi katmaya çalışır olduk Ama bu
aynen bu dönem olduğu gibi herkes kısa
eğitimlerinin hocası burada çok dikkat
etmek lazım deneyim denen çok önemli bir
şey var ve onlar anneannemiz de dedemiz
de biz zaten onlarla bağı kopardıktan
Sonra yavaş yavaş kendi deneyimlerimizi
sıfırdan yeniden bulmaya başladık Eee
Öğrencilerim de çokça görüyorum yani bir
bakıyorum herkes pinterest'in başında
yani bu deneyim pinterest'ten ya da
YouTube'dan öğrenebilecek deneyimler
değil ağacı ağaç fotoğrafından değil
ağacın yanından öğrenebiliriz
Dolayısıyla bizim anne annelerimizden
dedelerimizden öğrenecek en
öğrenebileceğimiz en büyük şey zaten
onların ne kadar Sürdürülebilir bir
yaşam içinde olduğu en ufak parçayı bile
atmadığı ve bu Tabii yokluktan geliyor
Yani insanlar orada yokluk bilincinden
savaştan çıkmışlar bu topraklar zaten
hep savaş görmüş ama mesela şeyi
biliyoruz yokluk diyoruz Hititler
Anadolu'da yaşıyorlar Çorum civarından
pud heppa diye bir kadın var bu kadın
dünyanın bilinen ilk savaşı Kadeş
Savaşı'nı bitirmiş ve Kadeş Barış
anlaşmasına mührünü basmış dünyanın ilk
Barış kraliçesi Eee Anadolu'da bu
toprakta ve orada Kargı bezi olur Kargı
bezi Çorak Toprak alan ne yapacaklar su
yok eee şey kullanırlar hayvan teze ile
yıkarlar içinde amonyak var Çamaşır suyu
olur Dolayısıyla bembeyaz kumaşlar çıkar
yani buranın hangi yöresini anlatsak
nereye gitsek hep başka bir şey vardır
ve biz burada zaten her birimiz kendimiz
neredeydik anneannemiz dedemiz ne
yapıyordu diye düşünsek zaten
Sürdürülebilir bir dünyada yaşıyor
oluruz Tekstil çok kıymetli Eee ve Ama
en çok zarar verenlerden bir tanesi
dolayısıyla her giydiğimiz her
baktığımız her dokunduğumuz şey de bir
kere daha düşünmek lazım teşekkür
ederim
gidiyor muyum
gidiyorum